basically our studio lines up to the map
if I'm actually navigating around our
real studio it correlates to the game
this is VR but actual VR you are
literally in a virtual environment it's
so freaking cool no Clint team got the X
n suit back just got back from their
headquarters in El Segundo - this is
arson it's like the easiest most
powerful piece of technology I think
we've ever had control of in the studio
we have Boston Dynamics - obviously it's
in the works
we have to make a sequel I don't know if
we'll trick everyone like we did with
the first but if it'll be a weirder one
really cool thing with the suit though
that we have not done yet is this suit
streams motion capture data into unity
where we can start playing around with
real-time motion capture I guess the
thing that I think that first is maybe
we can kind of make our own video game
but imagine you have a VR headset and
controllers that's cool because that
means it puts your head in your hands
into a virtual environment but with this
you can put your whole body into a
virtual environment so we're gonna have
some ego in all our videos from now on
right every single one name of the
channel blowing up I mean it's been
awesome but it's been a ton of work but
you know it's gonna keep me going is
knowing that at the end of this week Sam
is going to make us a video game with
the mocap suit and it is going to be the
best video game I've ever played
I can't wait this it is stressful like
basically trying to make a video game
from scratch again so I learn how to use
unity a few years ago making a fun
little game called secure digger as a
joke he actually made the game beer in
grave digger and can you tell her I'm
digging up Graves fighting out zombies
in finding Hinda car's computer Yipes
and it was then forever lost into the
ether of time and so I kind of abandoned
that whole practice and I forgot how to
use unity Sam's thirst for game design
was never quenched those latent dreams
have been sitting there simmering in the
back of his mind until today basically
we have this suit we can do anything
with it we have one-to-one motion
capture in real time in unity what's the
coolest thing we can do well we have a
lot of cool ideas but I think the nicest
easiest simplest most relevant one it's
just a simple you know
breaking-and-entering shopping spree in
area 51 I'm making a training simulator
when we don't rush the base let's use
our hands so let's use our legs so let's
just max out the movement of this suit
smash-and-grab bust open the boxes steal
the alien technology set little aliens
free we don't know what area 51 is
really like we don't know if it's the
same dimensions of the corridor digital
studio but assuming it is will be highly
prepared so I'm gonna research area 51
here and use that as the inspiration for
this game this training simulator it's a
simulated area 51 simulator unity it's
like a 3d program but it's got this
coding element to it you're not just
making things look nice you're
programming things to its end to react
and it's exciting as it is to hop back
in it's really daunting because I've
forgotten a lot of things that are
really important things like how to code
things after kind of revisiting some old
tutorials I now finally have my bearings
here we can actually make this game for
real I can't even focus do I've always
wanted to raid area if you want this is
the closest we can come to actually
doing so things you need to make an area
looting game you need your character
streaming from the extend software we
need destructible objects we need loot
you need any green boy assets or
anything like that
we'll have boxes people already just
have their pans and likes to kick open
stuff sweet things like like little ray
guns or radioactive isotopes in some
intergalactic merch Hillary's emails
like things like that basically the true
Maps just flat that's it really I'm very
excited for this game I'm super excited
because now that I figured out unity
again it's so freeing like everything's
at my fingertips I can do anything now
there's no limits this whole game I
pitched you guys that's just the
beginning should this be a game video or
I just like over-promised everything
there's gonna be a conversation tree
with every alien you meet you can decide
what career he's gonna have any break em
out and I am also building a feature
where you can't actually romance the
aliens after you save them whether they
are male or female these are all the
things slated for development there's
also gonna be an open world trading
system where you'll be able to take your
area 51 gear exchange it for real cash
if you talk about a lot of features Sam
here we go as you can see here we have
our scene
if our character here some boxes some
moody area 51 light let's make it work
so I'm gonna hit play here so okay well
the house is blown up but anyways here's
a guy seemingly in area 51 if you do
those little aliens in the boxes you
have a pair already just as a test I
mean the aliens still find hopefully
will be alive and we'll have a dialogue
tree and a romance system to break a lot
there we go break the boxes yeah check
it out here's the first-person version
to see here what he would be seen once
again he's blind you know he'll be
running around in the studio you won't
actually be able to see this perspective
very interesting once though it's really
cool anyways it's very janky still but
it's proof of concept hey Jake yo Jake
Jake what are you doing this is
clearance for in here right now
interesting design well my cover's blown
at this point AZ put a camera in here
listen there's been a lot of talk lately
about area 51 okay and I found out a lot
I'm verifying a page but the point is in
all of this there's one thing that I
know for sure I'll never have to worry
Oh am i Internet security that's because
today's sponsor is brought to you by
expressvpn expressvpn protects all my
information on the open Internet
meaning when I found out that this was
real I didn't have to worry about people
seeing my personal information out in
the open Internet expressvpn protects
all the browsers that I use it protects
all the devices that I use it protects
all the routers and all the networks
that I'm on and a monthly subscription
is just seven
dollarz brings me a lot of peace and
security okay it's not candy dude I get
indigestion when I get horizontal man
isn't that normal for just seven bucks a
month you can get expressvpn with a
30-day money-back guarantee and in fact
you can even get three months free if
you sign up for a year subscription by
going to expressvpn comm slash core or
crew that's just enough time to get
through I don't know say the end of
September okay that's e^x PR ESS VPN
comm slash corridor crew or just click
the link in the description of this
video and you'll be fine you want to
worry about people out there oh maybe
maybe I'm just on a site and I'm just a
guy yeah that's what he thought okay
that's what do you thought I bet you
don't know about this right all right
man we'll have a good one where you
going I'll see you later
hey Clint in crafting this world where
you are raiding area 51 trying to figure
out who are you I want your help to
select the beef I personally feel that
it would be someone with very large
thighs because they're gonna be
crouching most of the time this guy okay
this guy's quite innocent looking and
he's got flip-flops the world's most
highly evolved human this is you whoa
whoa this guy he's causing trouble he
got too drunk on Halloween and he
wandered into the wrong part of this guy
from like Tim and Eric who is the least
likely person the right area 51 and this
guy is almost top of the list
I'm suspecting he's in third grades he
has a backpack which makes him very
well-suited for robberies so we have all
these things working together basically
I need to create the space I need to
measure our studio basically with these
dimensions I'm going to rough out a
general space basically
and I'll populate that with assets like
walls
shelves boxes things like that and then
I need to do an actual live test was
claimed in this suit
we need to sync up your real-world
coordinates at the game's coordinates
okay and so basically someone hits
spacebar to open the door and in the
game that will see the door open and you
enter a 251 all right this can be our
sync point right here well this is the
origin point so basically our studio
lines up to the map that Sam created in
unity and right now he's just testing
like the barriers of the world to make
sure that like if I'm actually
navigating around our real studio it
correlates to the game it's nuts
go corner-to-corner now all right really
close we're really close go back to the
go to the other corner we are super
super close right now at the one final
test
now imagine in front of you is a box I
want you to kick it and smash it go for
it yes I think we're good in fact if
it's kind of hard to break into this
stuff I think it's gonna be a little
funnier and a little better it's like
kick yet no you didn't break it dude
that's amazing
my mind is blown my mind is blown as
well this is VR but actual VR you are
literally in a virtual environment
that's so freaking cool I've learned a
lot about how he's gonna have to
interact with the objects and break them
I got my aliens I've got my containment
door it's working
it'll be playable tomorrow hopefully
it's playable and also it's got the
romance system at this point I can only
hope it's just something to release yeah
I'm releasing it for you guys got like
seven customers I'm more excited than
anything else really looking forward to
finally playing this game after all the
hard work that's gone into it
small game but it's kind of a big step
for me this game is a two-player game
it's called breaking the area 51 and
free the aliens
this is how the game's gonna work there
is going to be one player in the motion
capture suit well after his long journey
through the desert in the battle with
area 51 troops his eyes have been
blinded by gamma radiation by the time
he walks into area 51 he's walking in
completely blind unable to see anything
that's where the second player comes in
that players friend is a hacker and has
hacked into the security cameras of area
51 and it's in contact with him via
radio to help him navigate through area
51 sounds easy right our first team is
going to be Peter and Clint let me check
your surroundings we're good to go now
quit when you run out immediately jump
to the ground because there's gonna be a
laser flying right over you're ready
don't play games with me here I'm
literally playing a game with you bay
doors opening in three two one
all right run straight ahead okay so
you're right - you're right
what's up for the wires dude okay stop
immediately to your left punch forward
punch forward I'm gonna make altar easy
I'm gonna hop and then do the camera
I'll be your hacker I just love it when
I come through kick the air and I hear a
box break you have one more shot at this
and then you're out reset to origin
let's do this alright alright holy walk
out walk walk a little bit more to your
right take two steps to your right yeah
right sorry they're good so you're gonna
step forwards a little bit and then
you're gonna you're taking a left okay
okay you're good yeah towards Dean's
desk
these days yeah right there all right
kick that punch it going keep going if
it fits or tear I do think it's weird
you're right
[Music]
you're not breaking it that's no versus
your boys look out alright and now turn
directly to your right
alright punched forwards but wait you
can sneak around sneak forwards along
those computers yeah yeah like sitting
there you go right above you watch out
there's a tripwire right here next to
your left foot crawl forwards back away
back away back away there you go now
crawl forwards a little bit more to your
left for you
bring the top in front of you I've been
I see oh no no it's in front of the
tripwire that's good you're good
[Applause]
do us the whirlwind kick quick did I win
you got a bunch of aliens do that mule
kick that random mystery mule kick for
alien student that first name was
absolutely chaotic but hilarious I have
no other way to describe it now we have
two more players Christian will be
hacking Nico will be infiltrating I've
watched a lot of Survivor they do these
blindfold challenges where there's eyes
and ears and a blind person it's all
about the very clear instructions
Christian and Nico have to beat clenched
record which is freeing for aliens but
not escaping so if they can 3/4 and
escape they're good so he lets a mech
have a bunch more cool game ideas like
this if you guys want to see them
consider subscribing to the channel so
you don't miss something oh don't forget
you see I think I was gamma rays that
these aliens are pooping out is just
like getting my eyeballs a good thing I
have my hacker friend Christian hey
Christian what's your have your name
what what's your hacker named sleepy
bear sleepy bear
eagle-eyed guys ready already alright
here we go
doors are opening all right all right go
ahead and walk straight into the room
and right as you get to the desks here
take a kick I brought two steps and kick
that's one alien all right all right we
got Jay all right take a left now face
to face the entrance to the studio and
walk straight the trip wires are blocked
right now
and you're gonna run into a barrel in
three two one kick up to the left a
little bit too much too far out of there
they go okay
behind you directly behind you holy now
go straight ahead two steps and kick
go on sleepy bear wake up it was blocked
for a second and then you knock
something that stopped blocking and you
were standing right there
Oh more precision strikes like Donkey
Kong punches just oh here we go game is
beginning with you three two one go
alright straight ahead right before you
get to the desk go ahead and do that
same kick right now kick it harder oh
you hit it to your right a little bit
kick when you're gonna go towards the
staircase if you're gonna take a step
over the tripwire when I say take take
one step two steps alright take a big
step over and walk forward bigger bigger
bigger okay okay wait stop stop okay two
steps forward two steps forward stop
now take a one a big leap over the
tripwire it's basically that first
computer there you go okay now now just
everything over there just start mashing
just live
yeah there you go
okay stop under the staircase just smash
everything under the staircase okay okay
you're not gonna reach that table that's
headed back to the other side of the
room
walk toward clintus now right to your
left take one step
and then kick the box take it take that
right there
[Music]
now there's gonna be a tripwire for any
of you as you walk towards the white
wall here so take one step at a time one
step at a time okay stop stop
take one a big tiny step over it nice
okay okay okay now you're back in now
there's a barrel right in front knee
with the last hop I did it just kick a
barrel and a laptop thirty seconds
No okay to your right more towards knit
more turn dig now yeah right there
kick it harder go go you're out of it
now to 5g borrow your head
plays out there right there
nothing in there okay ten seconds we're
gonna make our way back to my the exit
stop top top big step over jump over the
tripwire
you're a good hacker man that was sweet
yeah look at the man do you do this
either room is destroyed boom I'm so
glad that we have the ability to do that
that's a once-in-a-lifetime thing right
there
breaking into area 51 I had a lot of fun
doing that and I'm sweating not even
being the physical player that's the
first time I like horror mocap suit how
hard is it making this game I can't tell
if it's something I should say is easy
or something I should say it's really
hard because there's still a lot of Jang
keenest going on there but ultimately it
all does what it's supposed to do so
just like squashing bugs smashing alien
51 bugs now there's certainly plenty of
things I can fix and make better but now
that I've gotten here the road seems a
lot more clear head and I'm sure after
watching this you guys probably have a
bunch of ideas yourself so if you do
have one leave them in the comments
below we're gonna read all of them
because we are dying to make more that's
though if you want to see those ideas
come to life don't want to miss them
subscribe to the channel so you don't
and if you really enjoy your content
consider ringing the bell helps us out
that was really awesome Sam maybe you
should make video games it's just really
small ones